and here he is the rich eisen show
gorilla glue toughest player on planet
earth winner for this week he gets
himself an nil deal with gorilla glue
ladies and gentlemen san diego state's
own punting and kicking matters
appreciate it thank you for having me on
how are you matt
i'm doing well how are you i'm good
let's just start off with uh a question
that i have for you is it true
that when you got the call
saying that you were in fact the
toughest player on planet earth winner
of the week from guerrilla glow in the
rich eisen show you thought you were
being punked is that a true story
yes i get a ton of spam calls from
fake car dealerships telling me about a
warranty for my car or something so yes
when i didn't see the number i was a
little confused but i'm glad i picked it
up okay great and so uh you know you you
zach publishes to the stars was telling
you this was happening and you thought
like this can't this can't be actually
real right that's what you thought well
guess what guess what's real matt
it is all of this is real your leg is
real that is for damn sure
how how how did you get into kicking
matariza how did that come about first
my dad played football in high school
and my brother played football as well
my brother kicked and punted so he
brought me out there a couple times when
i was younger and
my parents convinced me well my dad
convinced me and my mom
that i should play football we were both
a little nervous about it yes but um
it was a great call by him and both my
parents have been incredibly supportive
ever since well i i just remember years
ago uh matt when i brought my jewish
mother to a michigan game when i was
there it was parents weekend
and she got confused when there was a
flag on the play when a kicker got
roughed and she asked what that was
about and i told her that you're not
allowed to hit the kicker and she goes
oh
then i would have let you play football
that's what she said to me
so is that essentially what you're
saying when in your household yeah with
you somewhat of that she was okay with
me kicking and punting but uh didn't
like seeing me go out there and play
wide receiver
well you're outstanding at what you do
um how how how does this how do you get
so good matt i mean i know that's a kind
of a roundabout macro question but how
are you so damn good at this
just a lot of work in the off season and
a lot of work in my four years here
we're very diligent here and the
off-season strength and conditioning
program has played a huge part
and my coach coach deacon has just
worked his butt off
dialing me in and getting me prepared to
go out there and uh dialing you in how
like what what are you what walk me
through your mindset as you get
ready to try and flip a field pin
somebody or split it up right as you did
this past week
well in preparation just we watch we
watch film from practice and we go over
inconsistencies or things that can make
you inconsistent and try to continuously
work on those but
when i go out on the field i just have a
a blank
blank slate in my mind i guess just
completely clear and
and uh when i get the snap i just let it
rip
and you're certainly doing that how far
can you punt one
matt how how what's the do you had 81 in
altitude against air force this weekend
um how far can you hit one
well that one was 75 in the air from the
line of scrimmage and i believe 84 from
where i was standing okay but i always
believe that i can keep getting better
and i know that to be true so i guess
the new the new bar to look for is 80 in
the air
so
where where
can you do that at sea level do you
think what do you think yeah absolutely
i fit i fit a ball as big as the one in
the game at sea level before just not in
a game yet okay so you think so here's
the goal let's be honest here you're
you're you're all backed up you're in
your own end zone doesn't matter but
you're you're just standing around and
you see color on the field other than
actual grass right and and so you're
you're standing in your end zone you pin
it on someone else's one you think you
can do that what do you think absolutely
fantastic
wow uh when when can we see you do that
matt i'd love to see um we'll see
hopefully this week we have a huge game
against fresno state um has big
implications for the conference and the
conference championship which is our
goal here what we
think about all the time through every
off-season lift and run in every
practice it's all to win
the conference championship so hopefully
this would be a good week to pull out a
big punt yeah no doubt about it matt
eriza the winner of the gorilla glue
toughest player on planet earth uh
player of the week right here on the
rich eisen show okay so um let's just
wrap it up this way when you hear people
say that punters and kickers are not
football players i've been fighting that
quite a bit larry david actually came in
studio this past week and said that he
thinks all kickers should be out of the
game and i laughed i don't think he
really means it matt i i don't i don't
ascribe to that by any stretch of the
imagination i used to give away t-shirts
that said punters are people too how do
you respond to that matter rises
somebody who kicks an 81-yard punt in a
51-yard field goal in the same game for
his undefeated team
i appreciate it that's a lot of
motivation for me so when i hear stuff
like that it motivates me to go out
there and and work on my craft to help
the team win games and also
build myself as an athlete i'm confident
that i can go out there and compete with
anyone on the field athletically and
proven that a couple times on some
tackles we had a
big game against a university of utah
and the returner
we were being told all week he's one of
the best in the country one of the best
in the country so when i was hitting
these big puns i would immediately run
down field and
he actually returned one against us um
scored a touchdown on it and then on the
next one i pinned it out of bounds and
then on the next one after that he
started dancing around back there and i
chased him down and and threw him and
and gotten his face a little bit yeah
and he told me to come back and try and
do that again and then later on in the
game i i hit him again and put him on
his back so that's
all that motivation kind of just
motivates me to go out there and and uh
do stuff like that yes
this is why you get this nil deal
matariza this is why you do so what
needs fixing you're gonna get glue you
you know what you're getting you're
getting a thousand dollar check right
that's that that always i'm sure comes
in handy yes sir um and you're gonna get
some some free glue you're gonna get
some product what needs fixing
around your parts currently the slides
i'm wearing right now are close to
falling apart so i'm looking forward to
that shipment coming in and hopefully i
can i can save the shoes i'm wearing
matt this is your feet we're talking
about this is your livelihood you can't
have this we're gonna get this fixed
exactly gorilla glue will fix that yes
fantastic
okay this is all coming in handy you
know i love your coach right you know i
know brady i'm a michigan guy so you
know i i'd love this guy he's
he must love you he i mean i'll defend
he's a line coach by trade he must love
you going down and hitting people and
flipping fields and pin and pinning
teams back i mean your your team your
team might sputter a bit on offense
doesn't matter send in matt let's go
stick him inside the other 10. uh it's
amazing it really is amazing what you're
doing matt really thank you i appreciate
it you are most welcome uh so congrats
on this and i guess last one for you you
seeing pro scouts around talking to you
ready to chat to you about
uh
really think they're allowed to to talk
to us yet but we do have a good amount
of pro scouts at our practices okay
which is always good
in trouble
okay all of us we have a ton of talent
here and um it's just good to get that
nfl recognition yeah the idea is to punt
on sundays correct matt
and kik do you want to punt and kick and
the pros you want to do both
what do you think the opportunity comes
i would love to i know it's it's not
common but it isn't someone has to do it
someone has to be the first
matter eyes
state which is currently 21st in the
nation good luck to you against fresno
state and let's uh let's talk down the
line okay thank you very much all right
there's our guy our punter our punter
and kicker
yes they're toughest players on planet
earth too right here on the rich eisen
show 81-yard punt and 51-yard field goal
in the same game
he thinks he can pin somebody from one
end zone to the other
i wanted to ask him this and maybe we
will like
when this season is over he could come
out right and get drafted
he's a junior matthew junior punter
coming out early hunter could come out
early be a factor third fourth round
pick why not i'd love i'll take them and
we had a couple guys this is number time
that the jets offense sputters
this is a weapon this is this is serious
business again yeah early on in the game
in air force
san diego state just up three points 3-0
and they're pinned
in their own end doesn't matter kick it
out of your own end zone and stick them
inside their own 15.
late in the game uh-oh
we made them burn all their timeouts but
they stopped us they got to get the ball
back here we go time clocks with each
first down it time stops with each first
down here we go
air force has a chance to win until
they're pinned inside their own 10.
game over
that's a weapon bro and the margin
difference they won by six 22-yard field
goal 51-yard field goal boom there you
have it smitch just texted me he's done
the 80-50 back-to-back games
he said that he can legit stand in the
end zone yeah and kick it to habit
downed at the one dude can't have broken
slides on those golden feet exactly okay
so he's either gonna use the glue or the
money to get to get the slides that he
needs hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here